buy them promise a new approach for on
immigration a Humane approach this is
not Humane they actually they failed to
provide basic welcome and infrastructure
life in Cuba is too difficult and it's
something that practically doesn't exist
anywhere in the world there's only one
very strong dictatorship
I've been traveling from Colombia for
seven months and I spent about three
months planning this three months before
I could come
that's from El Paso Texas which is being
hit especially hard by the migrant surge
shelters there stretch Beyond capacity
leaving migrants to sleep out in the
streets let's bring in former acting ice
director Tom Homan he is in El Paso and
Tom what are you anticipating tomorrow
and I asked that question now that we
have uh discovered the news that in each
of the last two days new records were
set by the number of people crossing the
Southwest border more than ten thousand
each day so if they're doing that before
title 42 comes off what's expected to
happen tomorrow night at midnight
well first of all it's three days uh
John they brought us a 30 000 people in
three days this is historic I mean I've
done this for 35 years right and it's
insulting to see that we handed this
Administration most secure border of my
lifetime it was immigration I was at
45-year low down 83 percent and this is
what we have I went down downtown El
Paso that where you're filming right now
and I I saw hundreds of them just
walking the street I saw one defecating
in a parking lot this is this is this
Administration majority gets on there
and said these people be moved they
don't qualify he's lying to American
people well if we're getting 10 000 now
I can only imagine after title 42 we're
gonna get upwards of 15 to 16 000 a day
right now border patrol has 29 000 in
custody in border patrol stations the
Border tracers are overwhelmed the plan
I hear from border patrol command is at
29 000 is when they start Mass releasing
people Mass releasing people may need
not even processed and and there was a
time of the administration least put
them on some sort of ATD
in the ATD they're signing they took the
GPS capability away from the equipment
so they can't even find these people
when they want to find them this
Administration is doing the complete
opposite of whether to tell American
people it's a sham yeah yeah I wanted to
ask you about that because there are
reports that because of the overcrowding
situation there will be releases of
people under the streets of some of
these border towns and that the bite
Administration is planning to release
some migrants who according to DHS quote
have been vetted into the United States
without being placed into the tracking
system so we may never know where these
folks are going and let me come back to
that Drone footage on that Levy in
Brownsville that we've been showing for
the last week or so first with Griff
Jenkins and now with Bill milugen and
we've we've made the comment uh Tom that
this looks like a Port of Entry but this
is illegal immigration when you when you
take a look at the people who are lining
up there in the levy to be processed by
cuss systems in Border Protection to a
large degree those are single men do
those fit the typical profile of Asylum
Seekers
no they don't what what your viewers
need to understand is that based on
Immigration Court yeah the last 10 years
it hasn't changed under this
Administration nine out of ten okay nine
out of ten of those people will never
get relieved from your course because
they simply don't qualify
so that what happens if they show up in
court or even if they don't show up in
court they'll get an order removal and
the secretary said to Dave those that
don't qualify will be removed well my
question to secretary out of the two and
a half million you're releasing the
United States ninety percent lost your
case how many are removed how many is
ice removed that number is pretty close
to zero because I have friends in ice
command and they're not even looking for
them at the direction the secretary and
people need to understand why all these
people are being released that we don't
really know who they are and they're not
being tracked by any any uh ATV
capability especially no GPS there are
thousands of empty ice beds thousands of
beds already paid for by the taxpayers
sitting empty
but they rather release them because
they know ninety percent get order
removal in the homeland security life
cycle report says if they're not
detained and they get order removal only
six percent leave that's what this
Administration is doing mayorkas as you
know Tom has said time and time again
that the border is closed he he made
that claim again today despite the
pictures that we're looking at listen to
what he said earlier
we are making it very clear that our
border is not open that Crossing
irregularly is against the law and that
those who are not eligible for Relief
will be quickly returned
do not listen to the lies of the
Smugglers this is what will happen to
you
you will be returned other times in that
area along the Rio Grande let's put the
pictures back up where we see that the
Texas National Guard has actually closed
the border and denied people entry into
the United States uh is it safe to say
that mayorkas has relinquished control
of the border to the Mexican cartels
or the strongest nation in the face of
the Earth and we don't have operation
control of our Southern border the
criminal cartels of Mexico do and he
gave it to him this man has no Integrity
this man is large American people he
lies under oath he's an embarrassments
and position he holds this is on him all
of this he took the most secure border
of my lifetime
and created this this is on him and I've
said I've said for two years he needs to
be impeached he the men and women don't
respect them they feel like they've been
abandoned by him and the
commander-in-chief the men and women in
the borbitrar besides himself the morale
is non-existent thank God for the State
of Texas thank God for governor Abbott
should be the secretary Homeland
Security he's done more secure the
Border than anybody yeah I think he
likes being a governor of Texas at least
for the moment Tom always good to talk
to you thank you so much appreciate it
you got it I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis